this whole thing about abundance and
attracting to yourself what it is that
you want and how to use mantras and
spirituality to make sure you have what
you want true spirituality is about not
wanting is about being filled with joy
from inside and then sharing that
outside it's not about attracting to
yourself what you want people ask me is
there a law of attraction yes and you
better be scared of it because if it's
true that you attract what your mind is
thinking you better take a look at what
your mind is thinking what about your
mind all day when it's complaining and
it's yelling at people and it doesn't
like stuff but if you're attracting that
way so you eventually catch on that it
is not about getting what you want it is
about learning to find out that what you
really want is to stay open and not have
conditions on that openness and then it
comes down to how do you do that are
people capable of doing that or is that
just reserved for you know some special
beings Buddha and Christ that have
walked the face of the Earth everybody
is capable of that if I tell you to pick
up five thousand pounds you may not be
able to do that so I've told you to do
something that you have never done and
you're not doing it so you may not be
able to do it but if you're actually
already doing something and I tell you
not to do it you're always capable of
that because you're the one who's doing
it hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because I need them because
I don't always wake up and feel
motivated to go take on the day and the
thing that saves me that helps me every
day is being around people who are
thinking bigger who are changing the
world and it gives me a little more
inspiration to go after my mission and
so I hope this video helps you go up to
yours today too so today let's learn had
a lot of Attraction really works enjoy
inside you are the one who's closing
your heart you close it you are the one
who's closing your mind you do that
they're your thoughts it's your feelings
there's nobody else's so you are in
there doing these things so if I tell
you the way to stay open is to not close
I don't teach how to stay open that's
more like finding out how to get what
you want I'm interested in you learning
to not close but a difference if I say
to you I want you to open your heart
right now you wouldn't even know how to
start
but if I say to you somebody says if you
don't like don't close you know where to
start right because it's happening
inside of you and you see the tendency
to do it all I'm asking you to do is
don't do that I'm telling you that will
take you the whole way don't worry about
opening worry about not closing there
are going to be events that unfold in
your life that naturally open you a
beautiful sunset a bird singing
sometimes you get what your mind wants
all right you open great nothing wrong
with that don't close
how come it only last a minute I'm going
to see a beautiful sunset you feel like
oh my God I looked into the face of God
then you go right back into your mind
with all your problems why
why don't you learn to not close once
you get some openness start to work with
yourself to not close and this is how to
get what you really want the teeth the
Deep spiritual teachings are really
teaching you how to get what you want
because what you want is to feel love
and joy and happiness all the time
and so if you can get that from within
you then can share it rule number two is
attract positivity with Gabby Bernstein
we're always
able to lean into two different energies
which is a topic we've spoken about
often here on the show
but when people say oh I want to get
myself into a attracting power I want to
manifest more into my life they often
think that it's something that they need
to do like I need to
make a vision board or I need to talk
about it a lot or I need to affirm how I
want to feel or I need to do do I need
to meditate more I need to read that
book when really the Simplicity is that
it's not so much about what we do but
it's about how we feel
when we feel good we attract more good
into our life that is a core through
line of this show dear Gabby it comes up
over and over and over again and this
card as it says when I'm connected to my
joyful presence I attract support from
the universe for me listen I try to find
even the most difficult circumstances as
an opportunity to lean into something
that's a better feeling vibration so
sometimes you may be thinking well how
could I lean into Joy when I'm dealing
with a diagnosis or when I have just
lost my job or when I am having
struggles in my marriage or whatever the
problem might be
this is when we really have to get to
work those moments when things are
difficult and there isn't joy in sight
that's when we have to do our best to
lean into the next best feeling
vibration rule number three is create
your reality with Joe dispenza your
personality creates your personal
reality
that's it
and your personality is made up of how
you think
how you act
and how you feel so the present
personality who's listening to this
podcast has created the present personal
reality called their life
so if you believe what I just said then
in order for you to create a new
personal reality a new life you're gonna
have to change your personality in other
words nothing changes in your life until
you change that's the way it is so turns
out the 90 of the thoughts that we think
on a daily basis are the same thoughts
as the day before
same thoughts lead to the same choices
same choices lead to the same behaviors
same behaviors create the same
experiences the same experiences produce
the same feelings and the same emotions
and those same feelings and emotions
begin to influence our very same
thoughts and our biology
our neural circuitry our neural
chemistry our hormones our gene
expression our immune system
all stay the same because we're staying
the same so then there's a principle in
Neuroscience that says that nerve cells
that fire together wire together you
keep thinking the same thoughts they
keep making the same choices you keep
doing the same things you keep creating
the same experiences that stamp the same
networks of neurons into the same exact
patterns all for the reaffirming of the
same feeling and you do that for 10
years on end
the firing and wiring of those
circuitries begins to hardwire the brain
into a very finite signature that box in
the brain that's created is the same
level of mind and if you keep doing that
it becomes automatic
and turns out that 95 of Who We Are by
the time we're in the middle of our life
is a set of memorized behaviors
automatic emotional reactions constant
habits hardwired attitudes beliefs
perceptions
that have happened just because we've
we've just fired and wired it the same
way so there's a good possibility then
in order for us to change we better
start thinking about what we've been
thinking about in changing we have to
become conscious of our unconscious
habits and behaviors and modify them we
got to look at these feelings that we
feel every single day instead of just
thinking it's a feeling say what is this
is this guilt is this sadness is this
unhappiness is this pain is it
frustration is it resentment what is the
feeling that I'm living by the majority
of my day now
that's lighting a match in a dark place
in Neuroscience is called metacognition
the word meditation means to become
familiar with that's what it means
so the more familiar with you are I
can't with I can't it's too hard I'm
never going to change it's my ex's fault
it's my boss's fault it's my country's
fault it's the government it's the
weather it's my pain whatever that
thought is that you accept believe and
surrender to on a daily basis that's
automatic
you have to become so conscious of that
unconscious thought
that it doesn't slip by your awareness
unnoticed you got to catch yourself
saying I'm tired I'm unhappy that
someone else's fault do you complain do
you blame do you make excuses do you
feel sorry for yourself that that
personality
has to change in order to create a new
life so then you have to become so aware
of your unconscious habits that you
don't go unconscious to them in your
waking day then you got to sit in the
fire of those emotions
and you gotta watch those emotions come
up and you have to sit with them and
know that there's something on the other
side of them now this is where most
people get up and say I can't meditate
or I'm going to call up my friend or I'm
gonna get on social media and make a
post I'm gonna turn on the foot football
game I'm gonna get distracted because I
need something out there to make this go
away and what we're saying is we're not
relying on anything out there that's the
that's the hypnosis that's the
conditioning we want you to just become
so familiar with that feeling that you
catch yourself in your waking day the
moment you start
feeling sad and your energy drops ah you
catch yourself so
there's an unlearning process or
breaking the habit of being the old self
process that requires
a lot of attention
a lot of awareness and it takes energy
you've got to stay conscious also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is practice
manifestation daily with Eckhart Tolle
the greatest obstacle is probably
when meditation comes out of a sense of
lack or neediness so you feel you you
are deprived of something be it money or
relationship or a living situation and
you feel there's a great lack in your
life and you desperately want this to
change
and so you perhaps
use manifestation in a way that is not
likely to work when for example you
use affirmations such as
I want a better job I want a job within
the good income and a life situation in
a nice place and I want this and I want
that
by making these statements
you're actually by implication saying
that you don't have it
so you're also by saying that you are
there's a reverse side to your statement
I want and on the reverse side of the
statement I want there is the statement
I don't have
and I need
and similar things please give me if you
you pray to us maybe God maybe you pray
to Jesus maybe you pray to Buddha they
do that in Buddhist countries maybe you
pray to a saint or whatever it is or you
pray to the universe and say please the
universe please give me this please give
me that
that also doesn't work very well if it
works it could be accidentally who knows
but
usually that greatly diminishes your
power of manifestation because it the
manifestation practice arises out of a
state of lack or neediness so there's no
powerful manifestation there
The Secret of manifestation is expressed
in one simple statement by Jesus and
that encapsulates all the books
that have been written on manifestation
and will ever be written on
manifestationist was one simple sentence
it says when you pray for something
believe that you
that it has been given or that you
already have it and then you will
receive it
so the important thing is he doesn't say
believe that you will receive it
says believe that you have received it
so there the secret is hiding in that
statement believe that you have received
it rule number five is change your
beliefs with Deepak Chopra there's this
feeling of unworthiness like I would
love to have abundance but I don't
really feel worthy of thriving can you
can you talk about that a little bit and
is that really coming from our alignment
with source and soul and I am or is that
more of an ego thing
no there's a difference between
self-image and stuff
itself for me I I use this expression we
sacrifice ourselves for our selfie
so your selfie becomes your identity not
yourself
and what is your selfie your self-image
trying to do it seeks validation
it feels either inferior or Superior
and it is full of fear that's what these
people have who say I don't deserve it
they've been conditioned right you know
somebody at a long time ago said you're
not beautiful enough or you're not
successful enough or you'll never make
it and uh or you'll never be such and
such and that creates what is called a
limiting belief in the mind but there
are ways to actually overcome that
information belief because once you
start questioning your beliefs
you say is it really true that I will
never be president of the company is it
really true that my husband or wife
doesn't love me is it really true that
I'll never be able to lose weight
whatever your idea of what your goal is
then you can also say how sure am I if
this is true and you know the more you
reflect on this and you say you'd say um
what is this doing to me why why is it
limiting me and what is the opposite of
this limiting belief now this is the
basics of what people call cognitive
therapy and now there's something also
called awareness-based cognitive therapy
and there's a woman who wrote a book
called
uh I forget the book's name but um
she simplified this in a very nice way
it's basically how do you overcome
limiting beliefs and you do that through
reflective inquiry you do that by
mindfulness meditation but you also do
that by going beyond the thought process
because it's our thoughts that are
limiting us if you go in meditation you
know in the Kabbalah and all these great
amazing mystical traditions
that's the realm that they call are
himself or you know the Buddhists call
it the dharmakaya once you're at that
understanding that that's what you just
used the einsof is um a source is the is
the theosphere if you want to call it
not the newest weird no sphere is the
mind the theosphere is the realm of the
Soul or if you don't like the word soul
fundamental identity rule number six is
study the Law of Attraction with Rhonda
Byrne The Law of Attraction
which governs our mind never makes a
mistake
ever it's a law and it's infallible
so for example it's the same as the law
of gravity so imagine that as a sidewalk
and people walking down a sidewalk all
of those people are being held to the
sidewalk by the law of gravity you don't
see a couple of people just float off
into the air and think oh the law of
gravity stop working for them you know
they're just like floating off there
goes a few more off they go no everybody
the law of gravity is holding everybody
all of the time and so it is the same
from Law of Attraction
um it it the Law of Attraction just
doesn't slip up and so if it didn't
manifest even though the person thought
they felt that they knew they were going
to get it the Law of Attraction did not
receive it in that way the Law of
Attraction received that they that the
that they didn't get it
it's the way it is so so I think it
helps a lot if somebody is I was so sure
I was so sure then you get to examine
the way that you felt and because
believe me I experimented with
everything I would see that something
didn't manifest and then I would see
something else manifested really easily
and so I would think back to what was
the feeling that I had when that other
thing manifested so easily so
um it works Law of Attraction works
every time how just like gravity and
rule number seven the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is shift
your Paradigm with Bob Proctor we have
here in the subconscious the Paradigm
and part of the Paradigm with respect
to money is it's a poverty thing
now this Paradigm impacts our thinking
there's a power flowing into our
Consciousness and the thoughts we think
are generally motivated by the
subconscious mind
now something that I've been pointing
out here recently on look at this
the subconscious mind is universal
intelligence
so when you have that Paradigm in the
subconscious mind that controls the
vibration that we're in
and the vibration we're in is going to
dictate what we attract because we're in
that vibration here on a conscious level
on a subconscious level and on a
physical so you're going to attract from
anywhere you go in the universe the same
type of thing that's that's what we're
attracting
so we're attracting people that are in
harmony with this and this Paradigm
causes our thinking to be along the same
level
now we've got to realize Even in our
ignorance when we don't know and we
haven't got anything our thinking is
hooked into Universal intelligence
and you will attract from wherever it is
in the universe whatever is required to
cause the problem when you hear people
say you know I just get one filled bill
paid and another one pops up bang
they're going to attract it
and sure as it gets dark they get it
now that's ingrained in our mind from
the time we're children
in fact
from the moment of conception in most of
us
and then we grow into it and that's what
we hear as we're growing up money
doesn't grow on trees and and over and
over you can't have everything you want
you know
and that is
um
that's got to be eliminated and we've
got to realize that is not fact
that you do not have to work harder
that you do less
and you earn more
and you've got to get the idea that you
can have money coming in from many
different places in the world dragging
right into you you attract it
and you can magnetize yourself to money
in all different quantities
just give yourself permission
to want the things that you want and
unless you believe that you're worthy
unless that you practice love you're
never going to think that you deserve
the things that you want right so tell
the story
okay so I'm probably gonna I mean
I'll shorten it so this the bottom line
is that so in
1990 I was a senior in college at
Dartmouth and my parents came to visit
from Western Michigan and we went to
this place called Simon Pierce which is
a famous glass blowing Mill and as we
walked into the restaurant I had an
experience
that you may be able to relate to and
that is I walked in and I immediately
saw this painting hanging on the wall
and it was about the size of a door only
horizontal and it was a Vermont
landscape and I was drawn into it
immediately like I was no longer in that
restaurant I was standing in that field
I could feel that breeze I'd never ever
had an experience like that with a
painting I've never had an experience
like that with art no I mean not like
that not like that I mean yeah my sense
was that this is very atypical for you
very
so I
kind of lost it the the the the
restaurant was quiet and then
I leaned back and suddenly kind of back
in the moment I'm like I'm gonna own
this painting someday
it just that was what was right there
and I looked at the price and said like
three thousand dollars I'm like not
today and I went back and I sat down and
that was it but the painting never left
my mind you see there's something called
The zeigon Arc effect I always say it
wrong but it's like there's a checklist
in your brain that when you have a
moment where you're like this is
important your brain puts it on a
checklist yeah it's like a notch yes a
notch happens and now your brain as part
of the filter in the brain is always
going to be kind of scanning the
subconscious to let anything into your
mind related to that incident it can be
positive by the way like with the
painting or this is how trauma happens
too like you have this high intensity
emotional experience that notches
something in your brain and now your
brain kicks in to remember
so uh bottom line is uh
I always thought about that painting
years go by
whenever somebody would say Vermont I'd
think of the painting
I don't know why I can't explain it
never wanted a painting before I was not
an art student it's going to Lost like
you're out collecting Arts no no no and
so I you know fast forward the story 10
years and my uh Chris and I are engaged
and we're gonna go up to Vermont to see
the leaves and immediately I'm like we
got to go to Simon Pierce I got to show
you the painting so we pull up to the
mill and we walk in and right in front
there is Boom a painting by the same
artist Gail Shepard and I'm like oh my
God it's here and we race all around the
place
and it's gone
and the funny thing was and this is the
way your brain works Chris was more
disappointed than I was
I literally turned to him and said it's
okay dude like it'd be weird if we're
still here after 10 years I'm gonna
track this thing down I actually said to
him you know what's gonna happen Chris
I'm gonna be able to buy this like 40
years from now it's going to be hanging
in the corporate Lobby of some building
and I'm gonna have to track down the
owner and pay like quadruple the money
they pay but I'm gonna own this man my
mission yes so a couple years pass and
um it's my birthday I think I was
turning 30 and Chris says uh Chris gets
a couple people too
give money and he said I could buy
anything I wanted with it so I had what
500 bucks now I'm pregnant at the time
with our first kid I should have bought
a crib or stools but for whatever reason
the zeigon arc effect takes over I'm
like the painting so I call the mill and
I get this guy on the phone I'm like uh
you know I want to buy a kale Shepherd
piece and I said could you send me
Polaroids and he's like sure and I tell
them the budget and he goes I'll send
you Polaroids of some of her smaller
things
and she's like blowing up in the
meantime right yeah she's a very very
successful Vermont landscape artist and
so I
I I say to him you know by the way
there's this one painting
and I describe the painting I'd seen
over 10 years ago and he said well that
was way before my time but I bet Gail
will know
and I'm like Gail you know Gail he's
like of course I know Gail she like
lives in in down the road
here's her number
so for two days I paced around the
apartment with 500 bucks in my pocket
driving Chris crazy because I felt like
what am I going to say to her and I must
be a weirdo I've been stalking this lady
I've been thinking about her for 10
years I can't afford a painting you know
what who am I to buy a painting like
what the hell
so finally Chris was like would you call
her I'm gonna call her you're driving me
crazy so I call her and I start talking
a mile a minute and she was amazing
and then
um I said by the way there was this one
painting and I go and I explain this
painting there's a stand of poplar trees
down the center and a big mountainscape
behind it and this beautiful blue
Vermont sky and geese flying information
overhead and
I could hear her thinking on the other
end of the line
and she said you know Mel I've done so
many large-scale
uh paintings over the years I'd hate to
mistake the one you're talking about but
I'll tell you what
what if my husband and I meet you and
Chris at the Mill at Simon Pierce and
we'll walk all around and have lunch and
I'll tell you the stories behind every
painting and if you don't see what you
like there I'll take you back to my
studio which is a couple miles down the
river and you can look at everything I'm
working on and if you don't see anything
you like there then you can go through
all my slides and see if you can find
that painting that you saw 10 years ago
and I said deal
so a month passes we go up to the mill I
walk in we meet each other she's amazing
she's like twice our age just incredibly
cool lady she's walking around as we're
walking around looking at these
paintings Rich I've got I'm like eight
months pregnant I'm realizing
these are 10 times the amount of money
that I have
I can't afford this
like I don't I don't have this kind of
money
and I'm getting like more and more into
that imposter syndrome what am I doing
mode oh my God I'm so embarrassed I'm
meeting somebody I idolize I don't
deserve to be here right wasting her
time because she thinks she's going to
get a Payday out of this correct we sit
down
and she goes now that you're sitting
down I have something to tell you
um
she said there's only been two times in
my career as an artist
that I've done two studies of the same
peace
and your painting is one of them
it's one of a pair
she knew all along she knew all along
she was playing games with you about not
knowing which painting yeah and she said
the sister piece to the one that you saw
all those years ago is sitting in my
studio right now where it's been for the
past 11 years
I start sobbing everybody's like totally
emotional her husband's like you should
have seen her when you when she was on
the phone with you it was like she saw a
ghost so we get in the car
and we drive to the mill
and when we walk in they're in the
center of this massive kind of Barn
Studio space is an easel with a painting
taped up with painters tape on it and it
was
the sister to my painting there were
slight differences not as much movement
in the grass but it was
one of the most extraordinary
experiences of my life it was as if time
suspended and I was
standing before that painting in 1990
saying it would be mine
and there I was 11 years later
standing in front of it
and then I realized oh my God I can't
afford this
and Chris walks over and he's like
what's wrong and I'm like just promise
me someday like promise me that I don't
need a jewelry I don't need a car like
just promise me you will buy me this
thing
and he kind of leans over and goes hey
Gail how much for the big one and she
said um
Mel can have it for 500 bucks because
clearly when I was making it 11 years
ago I was making it for her
and so it hangs in my kitchen
it's on the back of the book
um this is the galley though right so
wait is it in the is it I think so yeah
yeah and
um it's a reminder every day that your
mind is designed to help you get what
you want
I never stop believing
that I could make it happen
and when you tell your mind what's
important to you
there is extraordinary science
that proves that your mind has a live
and ever-changing filter a live Network
that changes how it views the world What
it lets in what it blocks out and if you
program your mind correctly
and if you're clear about what you want
to create your mind will help you get
what you want if you're not being
defined by a vision of the future
then you're left with the old memories
of the past and you will be predictable
in your life
and if you wake up in the morning and
you're not being defined by a vision in
the future as you see the same people
and you go to the same places and you do
the exact same thing at the exact same
time
it's no longer that your personality is
creating your personal reality now your
personal reality is affecting or
creating your personality your
environment is really controlling how
you think and feel unconsciously because
every person everything every place
every experience has a neurological
Network in your brain every experience
that you have with every person produces
an emotion so some people will use their
boss to reaffirm their addiction to
judgment they'll use their enemy to
reaffirm their addiction to hatred
they'll use their friends to reaffirm
their addiction to suffering so now they
need the outer world to feel something
so
to change then is to be greater than
your environment to be greater than the
conditions in your world and the
environment is that seductive so then
why is meditation the tool well
let's sit down let's Close Our Eyes
let's disconnect from your outer
environment so if you're seeing less
things there's less stimulation going to
your brain if you're playing soft music
or you have earplugs in less sensory
information coming to your brain so
you're disconnecting from your
environment if you can sit your body
down
and tell it to stay like an animal stay
right here I'm gonna feed you when we're
done you can get up and check your
emails you can do all your texts but
right now you're going to sit there and
obey me
so then when you do that properly and
you're not eating anything or smelling
anything or tasting anything you're not
up experiencing and feeling anything you
would have to agree with me that you're
being defined by a thought right so when
the body wants to go back to its
emotional past
and you become aware that your attention
is on that emotion and where you place
your attention is where you place your
energy you're siphoning your energy out
of the present moment into the past and
you become aware of that
and you settle your body back down in
the present moment because it's saying
well it's eight o'clock you normally get
upset because you're in traffic around
this time and here you are sitting and
we're used to feeling anger and you're
off schedule oh it's 11 o'clock and
usually check your emails and judge
everybody well the body's looking for
that that predictable chemical state
every time you become aware that you're
doing that and your body is craving
those emotions and you settle it back
down into the present moment you're
telling the body
it's no longer the mind that you're the
mind and now your will is getting
greater than the program and if you keep
doing this over and over again over and
over again over and over again just like
training a stallion or a dog it's just
gonna say I'm gonna sit and the moment
that happens when the body's no longer
the mind when it finally surrenders
there's a liberation of energy
we go from particle to wave from matter
to energy and we free ourselves from the
chains of those emotions that keep us in
the in the familiar past and we've seen
this thousands of times in fact we can
actually predict it now on a brain scan
I think uh yeah to heal by thought alone
uh we have to demystify the process so
let's answer the question on two levels
okay
uh let's answer it in terms of the
placebo and then let's answer in terms
of what we can teach people in order to
do that okay so if you think about the
placebo
how is it that you can give someone a
sugar pill
saline injection or perform some false
surgery or treatment
and a certain percentage of those people
will accept believe and surrender to the
thought that they're getting the real
substance or treatment without any
analysis they begin to program their
autonomic nervous system
to make their own Pharmacy of chemicals
that matches the exact chemical or
treatment they think they're getting now
was it the inert substance the placebo
that was doing the healing or was it the
thought that was doing the healing
so there are numerous cases in science
that show that between 10 and 100
percent of certain studies that are
placebo-based triple blind studies
people heal by thought alone all the
time so here's the question
do you need
the inner substance to do the healing or
if you understand the science and
mechanics of how the placebo Works can
you teach people instead of putting
their faith and belief in some exogenous
substance something outside of them like
a pill something certainly known can you
begin to put your faith and belief in
yourself
and begin to select an unknown in the
quantum field a new possibility that
already exists
and do the exact same thing you did with
the placebo but believe in a future
and allow your body to begin to respond
to a new mind and the answer to the
question is yes because we've measured
it enough times in our studies with the
brain so that's Point number one
the second point that is important to
understand is that people only accept
believe and surrender to the thoughts
that are equal to their emotional state
they'll never accept believe and
surrender to any other thoughts that are
not equal to their emotional state so if
you get a diagnosis in the first emotion
you feel after the diagnosis is fear or
sadness
you can think positively all you want
with five percent now this assigns five
percent of your conscious mind
but who you are by the time you're 35
years old is a subconscious program of
beliefs perceptions attitudes emotional
reactions unconscious habits and
behaviors
so then the person gets a diagnosis
they're feeling fear thoughts of the
language of the brain feelings of the
language of the body they're thinking
positively with the five percent of
their conscious mind but they're feeling
fear
and they could do that all they want but
it's never going to get beyond their
analytical mind and begin to have an
effect on the body so mind and body are
working in opposition
that means also then that if you can
change a person's
emotional state
to gratitude
to inspiration
to Hope
to love
that means that they'll accept believe
and surrender to the thoughts equal to
that emotional state and they'll begin
to program their autonomic nervous
system into a different Pharmacy of
chemicals now let's just make this very
clear now in Placebo studies
81 of people who have
uh depression if they're in a placebo
study and 81 of those people who are
taking the placebo actually respond as
well to the placebo as they would to an
antidepressant 81 percent that's a
pretty high study what that means is
they're making their own Pharmacy of
antidepressants right within the nervous
system is the greatest pharmacist in the
world
so what's the revelance uh the
significance of that the significance is
really simple
and people begin to change their
emotional state they begin to alter who
they are
it may take more than one attempt at
this because in that Placebo study they
took the placebo for six to eight weeks
now the pill represented the possibility
of them getting well they're thought
when they start looking forward to or
anticipating getting better and they
feel inspired when you combine a clear
intention with an elevated emotion
you're moving into a new state of being
now the brain and body are no longer
living in the past
the brain and body are living in the
future in the present moment and they're
beginning to produce substantial
neurological biological and genetic
changes in their body
but the placebo study for depression
that person took the pill for six to
eight weeks which means you may actually
have to change your state of being for
six to eight weeks before you begin to
see the change so I don't want this to
be a Panacea where you do it once and
you're better our students have healed
themselves a very significant
very very uh
most almost predestined genetic
conditions that medical science had no
solution for not just one student with
one condition but other students with
the same condition now we're seeing a
trend but it took them some of those
people
two years to do it by thought alone
so they wanted it more than their sleep
they wanted it more than their pain they
wanted it more than their social
interactions or social engagements they
wanted it more than breakfast to them it
was the most important thing so every
single day they took the placebo by
thought alone
and by doing that over time they were
able to turn the battleship around
so it takes uh developing the skill it
takes the science of understanding how
it works it takes changing a belief or
perception that you have about yourself
and your life and it's going to take you
feeling a little bit uncomfortable in
the process of doing it but to heal by
thought alone means that you have to get
to the point where you literally are
thought alone that's when you begin to
see the significant changes so in a
sense then it's not the personality that
chooses the body or the parents or it's
the soul that chooses it does that make
sense but if a person gets caught in
routine and gets lost in the Quagmire of
life
then the ego takes over and the soul is
diminished
and now the person is doing their best
to become a somebody a someone on
something be somewhere in some time and
of course if that's the journey
and the person is not willing to find
wisdom or look for truth then they can
play on that level for as long as they
want until they're tired of it and when
they finally get bored with it and
they'll they'll want to choose something
else and Eternity is a long time
wouldn't you agree
so then the Soul then says okay here's
the options probable lines of time
they're probable lines of time that are
the more probable than others
and
there is a probable line of time for
living in the same body and raising your
frequency to the point where you can go
wherever you want with your body that's
the ultimate yes or no and you can whip
red out of nothing and you can be in two
places at once and you can be on the the
uh an alternate universe and have a
whole life there and you can be
dimensional that's that's the freedom of
when you've mastered yourself and you've
mastered the conditions
but most of us
are headed in a certain timeline based
on our genes and based on our own
personal Evolution and that's what makes
this time right now so powerful
this time right now is the age of
information
and an age of information ignorance is
actually a choice
and people are beginning to realize that
I don't need a doctor to find out what
my disease is I don't need to go to the
library or talk to my teacher I can just
I can just find the information and
people are starting to wake up to
Greater understandings and that is
starting to become the collective and
that Collective energy in the field the
collective Consciousness the collective
awareness is changing the future of
humanity yes or no and at the same time
past is crumbling
there is economic collapse there's
political collapse there's religious
collapse there's environmental collapse
there's there's all of that is breaking
down journalistic collapse and well who
watches the news and expects to hear the
truth I mean it's just all falling apart
and it's becoming so obvious
to people that all of a sudden they're
realizing that the people that run the
world or people that are in places of
Power are actually really really worse
off than you and I
and the only thing that has to happen is
that we have to collectively become one
mind
and when we collectively become
one-minded we no longer are seduced by
those things and we are now like a flock
of birds all moving in the same
direction of those fish all of a sudden
moving as a school
nobody's leading everybody's leading
we're just connected and what do you
think we're doing when you tune in to
the power of love in this room don't you
know everybody dialing into that same
frequency is causing that frequency to
be in this room and if everybody's doing
it it's getting more collimated more
coherent more organized and if you put
your attention on it there's more of it
so then when you're leading with your
heart that's enough
that's enough
so then when you have a collective mind
and people are moving in that way and
they're no longer reacting to politics
or whatever and they no longer need
those things you're catching somebody
who's starting to awaken
yes or no and if you're focusing on the
Divine and that's where all of your
attention is you won't see ethnicity you
won't see skin color you won't see
anything of Separation you'll just be
like wow
nice costume to the masquerade I should
have wore that
it's crazy because then people go get
their genetics found out and you know
some of them you know just really have
an intolerance to some culture and
they're 40 percent of that culture
so
what makes this time for me so unique
and I'm speaking
personally
is that there's such a quickening going
on more things are happening in a
shorter amount of time would you agree
and if more things are happening in a
shorter amount of time it becomes more
difficult to predict the next moment
this point we're reaching this nodal
point is the point of in
unpredictability and the old is
collapsing and the collapsing of the old
should never be faced with fear with
bigotry with with with anger with
hostility with guilt sadness and shame
because that's how we've been controlled
all along
and by the way
I mean I'm not a conspiracy theorist but
if you want to control people manipulate
their emotions so as we move closer and
closer to that point the probability of
US changing our life the length of our
life not from low stress foods and not
from vitamins all those things are good
matter to matter
but stress is going to down regulate the
gene consume the body's energy and now
that's going to begin to Signal the gene
to produce the disease that the person
has inherited in the first place
are you with me still so when you react
to someone or something and you're
living by the same emotional state you
keep the same genes on the same genes
off and that's your genetic Destiny and
now the Awakening of this even if
even if we change little timelines just
this week we changed lines of time
you've changed something about yourself
you are going to walk into a different
future that is your genetic timeline and
now you're bumped off course you just
got to be willing to stay in the unknown
and be comfortable with it and that's
when you're at your greatest if you're
truly
in the business of change or creating
your life that's a big responsibility
yeah right I mean like we we ran our
event I said to the audience okay nobody
nobody forced you to come here right you
came here on your own you took the risk
in coming here
by coming here you also agree that
you create your reality that you're
responsible for yourself and your life
so if something happens to you you can't
blame anybody because of that it's your
responsibility to take care of you right
so then the fundamental question is and
I ask myself this all the time
at what point
do I stop believing
that I create my life at what point when
things go bad then all of a sudden I
didn't create that
that person is doing it to me right so
if we can if we can wire that in our
brains right that
our reaction in response to an
environmental condition
is causing us
to go back to the past that's what the
emotion is the familiar emotion is the
past
and I'm on the journey and I catch
myself doing that
if I'm truly in the practice every day
and I can cultivate a feeling not not
not on the spot then
that you you're not prepared your
meditation is the preparation of mind
and body for this
so I don't get up from my meditation
until I'm in love with life I don't I
don't create anything that's going to be
unlimited until I feel unlimited and I'm
in that space and if I'm practicing
feeling unlimited every day and practice
connecting to the emotions of my future
I'm I'm out of the bleachers and I'm on
the field if you're on the bleachers and
you're trying to not react to people in
in circumstances you don't have
the practice or the skill set
on how to create that emotion because
you haven't been practicing creating it
and why do we close our eyes and do it
because the environment is so seductive
why do we sit still and not move because
you're going to want to get up and pee
and eat and have a cup of coffee and
feel so so now you're telling your body
hey stay
I'm going to feed you yeah you're going
to take a shower you're going to get
coffee you can play with your cell phone
you can text you can talk trash you can
do anything you want but right now
you're not the mind I'm the mind and
you're gonna sit and stay until I'm done
and when I condition you to the emotions
of the future and I get a very clear
image of who I'm going to be this day
and I'm not going to get up until I feel
that way
I guarantee you you're going to come up
against all those unconscious thoughts
they're going to come up right there I
want people I want them to see it I want
them to become so familiar with it so
conscious if they wouldn't go
unconscious they wouldn't let that
thought I can't ever slip by their
awareness unchecked they've done the
work in the beginning of the day they
suppress those circuits in the brain and
nerve cells that no longer fire together
no longer wire together you're you're
breaking down the old personality and so
you say ah your body wants to get up I
gotta pee I want to have a couple I want
to check and you you watch your body
want to get up and you go hey hey hey
hey hey hey get over here you you get
back into this present moment and you
every time you do that it's a victory
you're executing a will that's greater
than an unconscious program and most
people lose their free will to a program
because they do the same thing today as
they did yesterday their body's on
autopilot and it's dragging them into
the same future habitually based on what
they did in the past so now you're
sitting there and it's just a little
uncomfortable and you want to quit in
your body and you go
no
you get over here and you bring it back
now some people say I can't meditate but
really they're actually doing it right
that's a victory too and then you do
that and you start watching how you're
training your body back into the present
moment then it's your body says well
you know Lewis it's uh it's it's 8 8 30
in the morning this is usually when you
watch the news and throw a tirade and
get angry right and you're what's
sitting here with your eyes closed and
you're off schedule so why don't we just
get agitated about anything so the body
starts trying to create images in your
mind so you remember your ex you
remember your problems so you could feel
that agitation what if you watched your
body do that and you said
no no no no no I'm not going to give my
power away to the past or that person
that circumstance in my life you get
that body back in the present moment you
lower the volumes of that emotion
that's a victory you're telling the body
it's no longer the mind that you're the
mind now that kind of work
is tedious in the beginning but I watch
people because when I have them do that
it starts stretching their boundaries
the known self that little box starts to
move into the unknown and they survive
and all of a sudden they're more relaxed
in the present moment the unknown and
they start feeling more satisfied so now
they're more ready to create so the
preparation for the day is to remind
yourself of who you no longer want to be
to know thyself to become so familiar
with the word meditation means to become
familiar with so conscious of your
unconscious programs you're not going to
go unconscious why because you did you
did battle today with that personality
that's creating the same personal
reality and if your personality is made
up of how you think how you act and how
you feel and you want to create new
personal reality then you got to change
your personality and that's gonna mean
then you're gonna become so conscious of
those unconscious programs that you're
no longer the program you're the
Consciousness observing the program
disentangling from that
is not easy that's why most people won't
do it that's why they get on their cell
phone and say let me just create a
little dopamine by just seeing if I got
a text from somebody I like you know
your phone's over there and you're no
longer regulating with something outside
of you this is this is game time so then
if you said
what thoughts do I want to fire and wire
in my brain with my attention and my
intention I think we're a reality
producing machines I mean there's no
there's no single individual on this
planet
who doesn't create reality unless they
have a brain injury or something but for
the most part most of us are engaged in
reality you know and we do cause effects
I think we reach a certain point in our
life where we stop learning and we start
feeling and when we use feelings as a
barometer for the unknown
it's a it's it's contraindicated because
feelings are usually a record of a past
experience so we try to predict how that
future event is going to be based on a
Feeling and we always return back to the
old self again so
I love the idea of how we can actually
produce effects I love the idea that
every human being is either lives in one
of two states of mind we either live in
creation which is growth and expansion
and and it's um health and homeostasis
the emotions of love and joy and Trust
make us feel connected to something
bigger than us or we live in a state of
survival in the state of survival is
living in stress and living in stress is
when your body is knocked out of balance
and the redundancy of that cycle over
time that imbalance that keeps happening
begins to break the body down and I
think the biggest problem for us because
of the size of our brains is we can turn
on a stress response just by thought
alone and we do it all day long
in that continuous redundant
being out of balance over time that
imbalance becomes the new balance and
now we're headed for contraction and
disease and feeling separate from the
field and being selfish instead of
selfless we begin to
live in a state of breakdown in a state
of um
uh disease and a lack of health and and
so then those emotions then of those
survival chemicals endorses the ego and
then we become more self-indulgent and
more self-important and more
self-serving
because that's what those chemicals do
so
we live in one of those two states of
mind now those chemicals tend to be
highly addictive so this is really good
dinner conversation we can talk about it
right
but actually breaking through that's I
think when you free yourself from the
chains of those emotions that that we
memorize when we actually break through
and our when we remove
that mind out of the body when we break
the emotion that's trapped in physical
flesh and the body's liberated that's
true self-love that's true Joy it's the
liberation of energy so the anger that
once was in there the hatred that was
once into the Prejudice that was once in
there is transformed it's transmuted
into joy and it's the same energy but it
just has a different spin
in so no one can do that for you
you know that that isn't something where
someone you know waves a wand and then
it happens you have to actually be
willing to be uncomfortable
as you break that addiction and be okay
with it and then the moment the body's
liberated and you feel that expansion
that's the natural state of being now
you say I love myself so much because I
went further than I thought I could go
I transcended some limitation about
myself in the way I think in the way I
act in the way I feel that's the
personality that's the identity
changing one of those things
really changing and not just like
changing your mind like I want vanilla
ice cream instead of chocolate ice cream
but truly changing something that
changes your neurology or neural
circuitry changes the chemistry which is
your emotions that signal the gene that
begins to change your very expression of
Health in a very expression of life
talking about when you make that
emphatic you know declaration word
you make that change
and it's undeniable
there's a biological neurological and
Quantum effect as a result of it well I
think I flirt primarily with the idea of
how subjective mind has an effect on the
objective world
you know Newtonian physics is about
cause and effect it's about something
outside of you fundamentally changing
something inside of you you know we are
an expression or a reflection of the
environment
so
as long as the environment is
influencing how we're thinking and
feeling we can only be as great as the
environment so and if we're thinking and
feeling equal to the environment we
could only create more of the same
environment you know the idea that we
can change something inside of us in our
in our Consciousness and our thoughts
and in our feelings
and be able to memorize both
neurologically in our brain and hardwire
that information install Hardware
and condition the body emotionally to be
a mind so mind and body are working
together
if we're able to maintain that modified
state of being then
there should be some evidence outside of
us so instead of cause and effect
I always love the idea of causing
effects and it's a cause and effect so
in the quantum model says you can cause
an effect and so I think where we get
stuck with that is the idea that
you know that it has to be predictable
that we should be able to know how it's
going to happen and and that is that is
I think our biggest error because we can
never control the outcome of the
unpredictable that's the quantum model
it has to be uncertain it has to come in
a way that we least expect that
surprises us that that leaves no doubt
that what we did inside of us produced
some effect outside of us and and when
you begin to have those small
synchronicities at first and then they
turn into larger and larger events and
you experience that
that awe and that Wonder or that joy and
appreciation for being alive I think
that's the natural state of being I
think that's
having that kind of sensibility coming
from within us instead of needing
something outside of us to change our
state when you have a goal in your head
it's not even a goal it's a fantasy it's
a dream when you have a book like this
you can call it your goal book and you
write out your goals and you go through
I'm just about to take you through bit
by bit stage by stage you go back to
that but you can look at it you can
touch it you can just make it real so
remember if you do not write out your
goals as a plan and write out how to
accomplish them you don't have a goal
you have a wish you have a dream you
have a Daydream if you want to go get a
pen get a nice little book like this you
can do on your phone too you can make a
document in your computer
and be prepared to make your goals real
so let's start now get your book pause
this if you need to go and find one
create one and I want you to pick a goal
and do not even start with I want to
lose five pounds I want more money these
are what I call wishy washy girls no
if you can make your goals really you
might as well make them huge big
enormous phenomenal so if you say well I
want more money that's why I would go
hang on a minute hey I got ten dollars
here there you go you go well that's not
my goal but you said I want more money
and I learned this when I was to work
with women who were infertile that come
and go you know I just want to be
pregnant I want to be pregnant so bad if
I was just pregnant I go well as I look
at your notes you've been pregnant six
times I know I keep miscarrying
so being pregnant is not your goal is it
what
isn't your goal to carry to full term a
healthy robust bouncing baby to deliver
a perfect baby to be a great man yeah
that's my goal why don't you say that
because you can be pregnant lots of
times and never have a baby or you can
say my goal is to have a perfect baby
how about this my goal is to get lots of
attention for what a nervous twitch
explosive gas that will give you
attention but that's not what you want
is it nobody wants exclusive gas
so let's start with a big goal pause if
you need to
take some time open your book
and write out a big goal now you can
have a career goal and whatever I'm
going to have my own company create my
own business invent something you can
have a relationship goal my relationship
is wonderful we grow in loving and
respecting each other and you can have a
health goal
but I want you to pick one only one not
three not five not ten one goal it can
be career it can be health
can be love pick one goal
and then I want you to decide why you
want that goal so much so the first
thing is I have a goal I want to have my
own business that's my goal and now
you're going to go to a next page and
write out why do you want to have your
own business so much and the more
reasoned you can write out why the more
likely
you will make that goal real so write
down why write down as many why's as you
can remember
you can come back any time to this and
think Oh I thought of another why and
another why to leave plenty of space
take your time and when you've done your
whys go to another page and write out
who will benefit from you achieving that
goal of course you will but who who will
benefit for instance if you have your
own business
you will employ people who will benefit
maybe your kids will go to private
school maybe your business will allow
you to help your partner have their
business
the more people who will benefit from
you achieving your goal the more reasons
you have
to achieve that goal so write out who
will benefit from you achieving a Who
how and why will they benefit you're
going to buy your mama house put your
niece and nephew through private school
did you think of your mind as like the
genie in a bottle that says your wish is
my command
I want you to understand that every
thought you think and every word you say
is a blueprint that your mind body and
psyche must make real so when you write
out your goals don't say I wish I could
be rich
I long to be in a loving relationship
write it as if it's already happening I
am a millionaire I am in a loving
relationship I go that doesn't make
sense it does make sense because your
mind only works in the present tense
when you say next year I'll have a
bikini body it doesn't know what next
year is and so you must write your goals
in the present tense I am I always I
have I do this new page is about your
discipline
how many hours a day are you going to
spend working on your goal
how often are you going to come back to
this book and look at it I want you to
write out I am
I always I have I do and I want you to
fill that in you see the best goal in
the world will not work if you don't
work and many people fail at this point
they write out a goal
my goal is to be a millionaire my goal
is to be famous my goal is to be wildly
in love and I think that's it
it's not and if you want to be madly in
love right all the reasons why but then
you have got to put yourself in front of
the kind of person you want to share
your life with
if you want to start your own business
and you have a reason why you also need
to have the discipline to meet people
who will fund you sponsor you joint
venture with you so I want you to really
understand that the best goal will not
work if you don't work you can have the
start point
but you have to keep doing many of the
most successful people ever say well you
know I had a goal Luther Vandross had a
goal to be a rock star
and people said well you're an overnight
success he went I don't think so you
know I sang Jingles for KFC for 12 years
that's a long night 12 years and people
said but Luther you're singing on
television that's cool you get paid a
lot of money for KFC I said yeah but
it's not my goal and he stuck it out and
many people have got so close to success
and had to keep going and you have to
keep going so
look at your digital and decide you will
give more to your goal give even more
work on it look at it write it out think
about it talk about it you must be
prepared to give so much to your goal in
fact you must be prepared to be
unstoppable in the pursuit of your goal
meditation the actual translation of the
word meditation means to become familiar
with so the first thing you have to do
is you have to become conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to notice
your automatic habits and behaviors and
you have to become aware of your
emotions that keep you anchored to the
past and if you can become so conscious
of the one unconscious states of mind
and body that they would never slip by
your conscious awareness again you're
becoming familiar with the old self so
you don't return then if you begin to
think about new ways of being being
defined by a vision
plan your behaviors review them in your
mind now if you keep doing that over and
over again nerve cells that fire
together wire together you begin to
become familiar with a new state of mind
at the same time if you can emotionally
cultivate your inspiration your joy Your
Enthusiasm ahead of the experience by
repeating that over and over again
cultivating that state it's going to
begin to become familiar to you so then
the process of change then requires
unlearning and relearning breaking the
habit of the old self Reinventing a new
self
pruning synaptic connections as we say
in neuroscience and sprouting new
connections unmerizing emotions that are
stored in the body then here's the key
reconditioning the body to a new mind
into a new emotion it's literally moving
from your past to your future it's
losing your mind and creating a new one
and so then when you begin to understand
that in the in that process it's going
to feel a little bit unfamiliar
uncomfortable and if you can relax into
that instead of going back to the past
continuously invest in your future
sooner or later it'll begin to become
easier and easier and easier and all of
a sudden when you least expect it
something amazing is going to happen in
your life and when that event begins to
occur you're going to pay attention to
what you did inside of you now to
produce the effect outside of you and
that's called human empowerment and
there isn't a person in the world that's
excluded from this equation if people
are really really believing that their
astrological sign determines their
Destiny then they will look for based on
their perception the correlations that
are equal to their belief system I don't
particularly believe that because I'm
born at a certain time under certain
house that has anything to do with me
creating the life that I want to have
right so
many people will though and because they
do they'll only they'll select like oh I
saw 11 11 on the clock well
you've seen three 236 on the clock and 4
18 on the clock but you're looking for
11 11. well then that's your reality
because that's where your attention is
right so I don't subscribe to that but I
respect that because that person is
going to keep that belief until it no
longer serves them and they're either
going to evolve their belief or they're
not and if they don't so be it but if
they do they're going to realize sooner
or later it's not working for them I
have certain beliefs right now
that I honestly am questioning that I
still think are limited beliefs but in
order for me to change those beliefs I'm
going to have to come out of my resting
state have to step out into the unknown
and really check to see and execute in a
very different way now
to build on that model
then it's going to require one foot
in the Practical world
and one foot in the Mysterious World
because I can't control all the events
that happen in my life but I can
certainly make choices that are going to
bring me closer to those experiences now
I also know from experience that when
I'm living by the hormones of stress and
I'm living in survival that you and I
and everybody else is always going to
try to control the outcome to try to
force the outcome to try to get in the
way try to analyze when it's going to
happen and how it's going to happen now
when that occurs
we're really bad
we're competitive we're manipulative
we'll hold on to things we're deceitful
we're greedy because that's what those
chemicals do so we're always trying to
control and force the outcome because in
a sense we feel separate from something
greater we feel like we're matter trying
to change matter we feel like we're
we're vibrating at the same speed as
everything else and so we have to get
what we want means we have to go and get
it and and and so then people start
mixing spiritual principles with that
phenomenon right so then
that's not what I'm talking about
because I'm talking about
if you're able
to understand that when you're living by
the hormones of stress that your senses
are heightened
and that you're materialist trying to
Define reality if you can't see it feel
a taste it smell it doesn't exist and
you're getting ready for something bad
to happen and be prepared and protect
yourself and that's how most people live
then everybody's doing that everybody's
mad or trying to change matter and soon
we're going to bump into each other and
there's going to be Sparks right so then
is it possible then
that instead of being defined as a body
living in an environment in a particular
time
that if you were to close your eyes and
disconnect from the external environment
to sit your body down
into transcend time
and to become nobody
you have the biological Machinery to do
this to become no one you're not a face
you're not a man you're not a
documentary filmmaker
you're not your past you're not your
future you're not a husband
you're not your body you're not your
emotions you're not your habits you're
not the predictable future of the
familiar past
your pure consciousness
now if you are going to heal your body
by thought alone
if you are going to create some event in
your external environment by thought
alone and if you are going to transcend
Time by thought alone then you have to
become thought alone
and so when people start to really
realize that they can change the neural
circuitry in their brain by thought
alone send new emotional signals that
begin to select and up regulate new
genes and down regulate other genes and
it may take knocking on that door
for extended periods of time till
finally the gene is programmed because
it took them 10 years to program the
gene for the disease it may take them a
few years to reprogram the gene
now we're talking about pragmatist we're
talking about someone who's applying
some principles and so then when that
occurs
and the energy that was sitting in these
hormonal centers of survival of anger
and fear and guilt and shame the energy
kind of moves up a little bit we've
measured This Heart starts to open gets
more coherent the field around the body
begins to grow we've measured that the
person feels more like energy less like
matter they feel like more like wave
less like particles they're not afraid
of the unknown they let's go ahead and
answer that really quick he said like
the greatest part right now
you said knocking on the door I was like
Yeah ironic
[Music]
oh thank you
all right hopefully you didn't lose your
train of thought so
they're not afraid of the unknown
they're craving them they're trusting in
the unknown
and that that kind of expanded energy
is now they're no longer
enslaved emotionally to the Past
they're no longer an identity that's
connected to a disease
they're no longer a body who's addicted
to an emotion they're no longer trying
to forecast the future based on the past
they're no longer a man they're no
longer a woman they're no longer a nurse
they're no longer black they're no
longer white they're no longer anything
they are they are they are completely
poised in the present moment and that
that that present moment produces a
liberation of energy because the body is
no longer
held to the chains of the past and that
liberation of energy then begins to
produce a biological transformation in
the brain and the body we've seen it the
brain gets highly coherent gets super
organized the person feels whole
we've measured that their heart moves
into a state of joy and and love and
gratitude we measured that the field
around our bodies and hands we measure
that and the person could no longer
cares about the future of the past
they're happy in the present moment they
no longer want anything because they're
whole
and if you're whole it's impossible to
want and that's the moment it happens
and so kind of this Paradox that begins
to occur so why am I explaining it like
this because I want to answer the
ultimate question of what you're asking
is that there's an intelligence that's
giving us life
it's keeping my heart beating and
digesting my food and food and
organizing trillions of functions per
second in every cell of my body I'm not
doing that I'm having a conversation
with you as a free-willed subject of
consciousness
but there's an intelligence within me
that's always endorsing who I'm being
and that intelligence is a Giver of Life
so to demystify it then and this is
where
i s i part from the spiritual community
because when your will
matches its will
when your mind matches its mind when
your love for Life matches its love for
life it begins to work in ways that are
mysterious now
why is that important because the
mysterious is the unknown and the
unknown is unexpected and the unexpected
should bring a surprise and that
surprise should be outside of my current
beliefs if it's happening how could I
expect the supernatural to happen if I'm
expecting it to happen
that it's impossible but if I'm in the
unknown and I'm open
to possibility then I should be able to
create an unknown experience that I
can't predict the emotion or the future
event of how it's going to occur when
it's going to occur it's not my job and
the side effect of that is this
mysterious surprise that changes my
biology from the new experience and then
causes me to change my beliefs and I've
I've had enough of my own mystical
moments in the midst of that mystical
experience I have said in the midst of
it I have this all wrong I have said it
right in the midst of the experiment I
am doing this so wrong because I was so
programmed into this box of belief
but the only way the unexpected could
happen is giving up expectation which
means you have to surrender that belief
how it's going to happen or when it's
going to happen I can't predict that so
then that same intelligence that's
giving me life according to the quantum
model of reality is the same
intelligence that's creating supernovas
and causing flowers to bloom it's it's
within us and all around us it's it's a
very wave of quantum physics I can't
control that I can't expect how the
particle is going to appear or when it's
going to appear but it's not my job
my job is to move into different states
of being and be open to the mystery of
how it's going to happen so
if I said to you today Ben that I had
all the answers
to everything I would I would certainly
be limiting this conversation but I am
open to the to the mystery of life and
the Mystery of Life then means that if
we're asking certain questions
and we believe we we even speculate that
it's possible and someone has to step
out into out of their present beliefs to
see if it is
and so I'm not interested in the natural
I'm not interested in the normal
I'm interested in the Supernatural the
supernormal and I believe from my
present state of ignorance of course if
we're going to use the word belief
that you don't have to be a Buddhist
monk
you don't have to be a nun with 40 Years
of devotion you don't have to be a
religious scholar you don't have to be a
researcher you don't have to have a PhD
to do this
that common people around the world can
do the uncommon and if they're given the
right understanding
and the environment is set up
where they can begin the application of
that
and I have looked at over a thousand
brain scans of people in meditation and
I can tell you that you and I are at our
absolute best when we get beyond our
analytical mind when we get Beyond
ourselves that's the moment
that the brain gets so organized and so
coherent the front of the brains talking
to the back of the brain the right side
of the brain start on the left side of
the brain there's this synchronization
this psychic Union going on a flow
and the person has tears of joy rolling
down their face that Gestalt moment
that that
Transcendent event for the person is
completely subjective but my interest is
measuring that subjective experience and
we're capturing amplitudes of energy in
people's brains that are 26 000 to 40
000 times normal during that experience
now
they can't make their brain do that it's
happening to them and the inner event
that's happening to them is more real
than any past event and that's the
moment I know their belief is changing
can you teach your body emotionally
what the future reality that you want to
live in feels like before it happens now
this is very difficult if you've been
conditioned into believing something in
your outer world has to change to make a
way take away the emptiness or the lack
to make you feel differently this is
saying actually feel the emotion before
it happens and don't wait for the
experience to occur teach your body what
the feeling will be before it occurs if
the environment signals the Gene and the
end product of an experience in the
environment is an emotion you're
signaling the gene ahead of the
environment and genes make proteins and
proteins are responsible for the
structure and function of your body and
the expression of proteins is the
expression of life so teach the body
emotionally to self-regulate to believe
it's living in an environment that's
flourishing that's wonderful keep
practicing it and it'll become familiar
to you and the process then
creates a new identity and it's not
difficult once you understand what
you're doing and why you're doing it and
the more you combine all those different
branches of science and make it in a
simple way to understand if people
understand the what and the why the how
gets easier because you can assign
meaning to what you're doing and it
becomes instrumental so get a group of
people a thousand people 1500 people 2
000 people into a room
teach them that information whether
they're coming for wealth or health a
relationship a new career a mystical
experience get them all together
and teach them and measure what can take
place in one week period of time and I
assure you that's more than 75 percent
of the people that go through and go all
in and Retreat from their lives and
remove the same stimulation from their
environment and not be in the same
conditions and teach them that
information and give them numerous
opportunities to apply it and numerous
opportunities to get Beyond themselves
all you need is that first person that
stands on the stage and says hey I
walked in here with Parkinson's disease
I have no idea what happened but I'm not
trembling anymore and boy that last
thing just something clicked for me and
the person in the audience is watching
the four minute mile right in front of
them and going wow that guy looks like
he's not a vegan he doesn't look like
he's particularly in shape but his
Parkinson's went away and wow I mean if
he could do it I could do it and
somebody else changes their belief and
now that's a footprint and Consciousness
get enough people doing that
by the end of the week you're going to
see things we've seen blind people
seeing deaf people hearing that once not
twice people with Strokes for 10 years
lift their arms up again we've seen
people step out of wheelchairs people on
crutches drop their cracks I mean you
see
and the body literally recalibrates to a
new mind and and they're not
intentionally trying to do anything
they're just becoming somebody else but
the process of overcoming
is the process of becoming and if you
teach people that formula and you get
just one or two people doing it it's
just going to become an infection and
it's gonna Wellness is gonna spread just
like disease I think it's a time in
history where it's not enough to know
it's a time in history to know how
and if you think about it um
most people live their life in a habit
they think the same thoughts they
perform the same actions they live by
the same emotions but they secretly
expect their life to change
but how you think how you act and how
you feel is called your personality and
your personality creates your personal
reality that's it so if you think 60 to
70 000 thoughts in one day and ninety
percent of those thoughts are the same
thoughts as the day before the same
thoughts always lead to the same choices
the same choices always lead to the same
behaviors the same behaviors create the
same experiences and the same
experiences produce the same emotions
and those same emotions then drive your
very same thoughts and so you get caught
in this kind of biological neurological
and Quantum fixated pattern
so then the hardest part about change
really in creating the life that you
want being defined by a vision of the
future instead of a memory of the past
is not making the same choices you did
the day before and the moment you do
that you step into the unknown now you
and I have been conditioned and
hypnotized into believing that the
unknown is some scary place but when you
begin to realize the unknown is the
perfect place to create from that void
of unpredictability that uncertainty
that unfamiliarity is really the quantum
place of uncertainty where all
manifestations come from so when you and
I become comfortable living in that
unknown place I think then that we begin
to manifest the things we want in our
lives so for me personally
I want to execute and be defined by a
vision of the future instead of the
memories of the past so most people's
brains are organized to reflect
everything they know in their life their
brain is a record of the past
and if you feel the same way every
single day and feelings and emotions are
the end product of past experiences it
means number one nothing new is
happening in your life and number two
those emotions are keeping you anchored
to the past if thoughts are the language
of the brain and feelings are the
language of the body and how you think
and how you feel creates a state of
being most people are literally
biologically neurologically chemically
genetically and even Quantum wise
connected to a past so then the question
is the fundamental question is
can you believe in a future that you
can't see or experience with your senses
yet but you've thought about enough
times in your mind that your brain has
literally changed to look like the
experience has already occurred now the
latest research in neuroscience and
neuroplasticity tells us we can change
our brain to look like the event has
already occurred and can we begin to
emotionally Embrace a future reality
that's a potential in the quantum field
and begin to emotionally embrace it to
such agree that we fall in love with
that future reality that our bodies Our
unconscious mind begins to believe it's
living in that future reality in the
present moment and we're signaling new
genes in new ways to change our body to
look like the experience has already
occurred in preparation for the event
now think about this so making our inner
World more real than the outer world
right but not only that
you have to then understand that when
you truly do this properly you're not
waiting for your healing to feel whole
you're not waiting for your success to
feel empowered you're not waiting for
your wealth to feel abundant you're not
waiting for your new relationship to
feel love you're not waiting for the
mystical moment to feel awe that's the
old model of reality of cause and effect
waiting for something outside of you to
change how you feel inside of you and
when you feel better inside and you pay
attention to whoever whatever caused
that that's that's cause and effect and
when you begin to make the correlation
between what changed you from outside
and inside you create an associate of
memory the quantum model of reality
begins to say then you have to teach
your body emotionally how that future is
going to feel like before it's made
manifest in other words you have to feel
awe in order for the mystical moment to
happen you have to feel uh oh abundance
before your wealth can occur you have to
feel in love with life before your new
relationship happens and so we're not
defining Reality by our senses because
we're not waiting then for anything
outside of us to change how we feel
inside of us so if there's physical
evidence in your brain and body to look
like the experience has already occurred
physical evidence
because the epigenetic model of reality
says you can change your body by thought
alone you and neuroplasticity says you
can change your brain by thought alone
so if there's physical evidence to look
like the experience has already occurred
well relax because the experience is
going to find you and it's going to come
in a way that you least expect
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to unlock
the power of manifesting check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there there is a law of thinking
like everything else like all of nature
there is a universal energy or law of
mind or subconscious mind whatever you
want to call it but to me it means the
power that is within me